Big story this week:
there's been a lot friction
between the Trump Administration
and their top health official,
Doctor Anthony Fauci.
The President's often contradicting
Fauci's medical opinion about COVID-19.
The White House even sent out a document
detailing all the times
Doctor Fauci has been wrong.
Well, the President insists he has
a good relationship with the doctor,
but I wanted to dig a little deeper.
So here to talk about the
President's relationship
with Doctor Fauci is
Senior White House Advisor,
Ken Wheatley.
Hello Ken, good to see you.
Hello, Conan.
I'm happy to answer any and all questions
with 100% honesty and transparency.
Great, great.
Well, no, no, no, no, no.
Ken, Ken!
Ken, come back.
I didn't ask anything yet.
It seems like the White House is making
a pretty aggressive effort
to hurt Doctor Fauci's reputation.
No, nothing could be
further from the truth.
The President loves Doctor Fauci
and his constant stream of buzzkill news.
Fauci's a lot of fun!
Okay, look.
I hear you.
I know that Fauci delivers
a lot of difficult news,
but don't you think America needs
to hear it from someone like Doctor Fauci,
a medical professional who
has a lot of credibility?
Does he though?
I mean, he's been wrong on
quite a few things, Conan.
Early on, maybe, a few missteps,
but back then nobody knew
much about how COVID spreads.
I'm not even talking about
his COVID statements, Conan.
Doctor Fauci's been wrong a
lot, and it's all in here.
Give me an example.
Give me an example of
when he's been wrong.
Well, I looked up his office
Oscar pool from last year,
and had had Ford V Ferrari winning it all.
Is that someone you can trust?
A lot of people picked
Ford V Ferrari, they did.
Okay well, Doctor Fauci said, and I quote,
"That TV show The Office didn't really
"hit its stride until Steve Carell left".
Okay, yeah.
All right, that's clearly not accurate
or a good take on something,
but I don't think it's a huge deal.
Hang on, there's more.
On his drivers license it says he's 5'10".
Okay, that's a demonstrable lie.
And guess what Fauci puts on his hotdogs?
I don't know, ketchup?
Cream cheese!
And his favorite James
Bond is Timothy Dalton!
Oh my, oh god.
That's bad.
Yeah, you know when I saw The Sixth Sense
with Doctor Fauci he kept leaning over
and whispering, "There's no way
"Bruce Willis is actually dead".
And I once saw him bite into a zucchini,
then spit it out and say, "Gross!
"I thought it was a cucumber".
Honest mistake, right?
What kind of a lunatic takes a bite
out of a whole cucumber?
All right, okay.
But none of what you're
saying has anything to do
with his medical opinion.
All right, well okay.
How can you trust his medical opinion
when he tells everyone to
wear a protective mask,
and yet here's a photo
of Fauci without a mask.
That photo is from the 1990s!
He was receiving the
Presidential Medal of Freedom
for his groundbreaking AIDS research!
It's obviously you guys are just trying
to tarnish his reputation because he's
polling better than Trump.
Well, that's just your opinion.
No, no, that's actually a fact.
Well, as the President says,
facts are just opinions
that run like a girl.
But as I said, we all adore Doctor Fauci,
and hang on, the suns
getting in my eyes here.
There, that's much better.
We all adore him and
we are behind him 100%.
Okay, Ken Wheatley, everybody.
Oh, Fauci stayed with
Quibi after the free trail!